[Musique]
mais d'abord Michael ce qu'il faut
retenir de l'actualité du jour dans le
département et pour commencer
l'ivelinois Gérard Larcher a été élu à
la présidence du Sénat aucune surprise
puisque la droite avait conservé la
majorité à la Chambre haute après les
élections sénatoriales du 24 septembre
Gérard Larcher obtenu cet après-midi 218
voies sur 348 votants il remplit donc
pour un cinquième mandat de président
postes que l'ancien maire de Rambouillet
occupé de 2008 à 2011 et depuis 2014 je
le disais dans les sites bientôt deux
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie dans
les Yvelines elles font partie des 238
nouvelles brigades qui vont être
déployées d'ici 2027 sur le territoire
français annonce cet après-midi
d'Emmanuel Macron lors de son
déplacement à Tonneins dans le
Lot-et-Garonne l'une de ces brigades
divinois sera fixe et implantée dans la
commune de Beynes l'autre sera mobile
est basée à Rambouillet selon l'Élysée
le but et je cite de répondre à la
hausse de la délinquance en milieu rural
et de renforcer le lien entre les
populations et les de l'ordre trois mois
après les émeutes le premier village
100% inclusif de France s'implante dans
les Yvelines et c'est à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce matin lundi à
2 octobre avait lieu la pose symbolique
de la première pierre par la Fondation
Anne De Gaulle c'était en présence
d'Aurore berger ministre des Solidarités
et des familles et de Fadila à katabi à
ministre délégué des personnes
handicapées pendant longtemps on n'a pas
voulu voir les personnes en situation de
handicap pendant longtemps on a préféré
presque les parquer dans des
établissements qui étaient dédiés mais
qui étaient éloignés de nos
centres-villes de nos centres bourg là
l'objet même de cet établissement c'est
justement de ne pas en être un d'être un
village d'être un village qui doit
pouvoir accueillir tout le monde c'est à
dire des personnes qui ne sont pas en
situation de handicap qui vont pouvoir y
circuler qui vont pouvoir côtoyer tout
simplement d'autres Français sans faire
mention de ce handicap et ça je crois
que c'est une avancée magnifique c'est
toute l'innovation qui est mise ici au
service des personnes en situation de
handicap il va y avoir un campus
recherche donc très beau projet un
projet en fait très global qui fois bon
il y a les professionnels du
médico-social mais également toute la
partie recherche pour pouvoir encore
améliorer et apporter les réponses les
plus adéquates les plus j'allais dire
responsables et qui répondent au plus
près des personnes en situation de
handicap baptiser Agora le village est
situé avenue du parc en face de la
déchetterie les détails de ce projet en
seconde partie de l'émission avec
l'invité du 7 8 Jean van droule au
président de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
alors autre ministre en visite dans les
Yvelines c'est Jean-Noël barreau le
ministre délégué en charge du numérique
à assister à l'inauguration du nouveau à
data center téléhaus s'installer à
Magny-les-Hameaux ainsi de plus de 10000
mètres carrés consacrés au stockage de
données nous reviendrons sur cette
information demain dans le 7 8 la 7e
édition du salon iconomie job c'est
demain le rendez-vous se tient au Pôle
Universitaire Léonard de Vinci à
Courbevoie dans les Hauts-de-Seine plus
de 40 exposants seront sur place pour
faire découvrir les métiers du
médico-social et de la petite enfance
vous pourrez aussi découvrir différentes
formations du secteur et les emplois
disponibles un programme également cette
année un escape game découverte des
métiers un kit de simulation du
vieillissement un atelier coaching mais
aussi un job dating sur les métiers du
secteur pour terminer Michael depuis
aujourd'hui c'est le coup d'envoi de la
nouvelle campagne de vaccination contre
le covid-19 elle est ouverte à tous et
sans âges minimum vous pouvez dès
aujourd'hui vous faire vacciner chez
votre médecin ou à la pharmacie il
s'agit de vaccins ciblant le sous
variant domicron xbb 1.5 devenu
majoritaire toujours sans obligation
cette vaccination reste fortement
conseillée pour les personnes les plus à
risque une vaccination toujours prise en
charge à 100% par l'Assurance Maladie
pour l'ensemble de la population pour
recevoir cette dose de rappel vous devez
attendre au moins 6 mois depuis votre
dernière injection contre le covid-19
merci Michael et si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous fait
réagir près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78